- Ash, come here...stand...
No, don't touch my...you
just nip flashed me!
Stand!
(bouncy music)
- Hi there, I'm Aria, and
as the camming industry
continues to thrive, I
figure, "What better way
"to learn more about this
unique and fascinating
profession than by spending
the day with a cam girl?"
Oh, that's locked.
I'm meeting Scarlet, a cam
girl who, like many others,
earns money by performing
online in nude cam shows.
Scarlet is also a vegan and animal
lover, who owns a dog named Ash.
- I started camming in April of last year,
so I've been camming almost a year now.
- A year, wow.
After I eventually realized
that a pet store might not be the most
appropriate place to discuss camming,
we head back to Scarlet's apartment.
What is this?
- Oh, it's just
one of my presents that I get.
- You get presents?
- I do get presents.
- What's in it?
- I have no clue.
You wanna try to guess?
What does it feel like?
- What do you say, what do you think?
- It's a pony.
- It's a pony?
- It's a pony, I put that
on my wishlist, you got me.
- What are some stuff
you've got on your wishlist?
- My desk in my room and my carpet,
and my mattress topper
was from my wishlist.
- So basically your entire house is...
- Yeah, everything.
- Is there a chance
this is going to be inappropriate?
- Possibly. (ripping)
- Oh, actually, this is
not dirty, we're good.
- Fantastic.
- Let's see.
Aw, it's a choker!
- It's a choker.
Yes.
- A really cute one.
- I definitely knew what that was.
Is that a bath mat? That's
a gigantic bath mat.
Rocky, you wanna come over
here, give her a whirl?
How is that for ya?
What would you give that
on a scale of one to ten?
- That's a good number.
Scarlet then takes us into her bedroom,
where she will usually cam from.
- Can you say hi? (laughs)
This is a loveince, this is what a
lot of girls use on Chatter Bee.
Basically, this goes inside
you with the tail hanging out.
So it connects to your
laptop, and when you get tips
on the website, it makes this buzz,
so depending on how much you tip
is how long it buzzes for and how hard.
- She also shows more of the
toys she'll often use on cam.
- Nipple clamps.
- Oh my.
- I have handcuffs, whips...
- This is like
a very dirty version
of Mary Poppins' purse.
- Yes! I have a ball gag, it's like a...
and it nipple clamps as well.
♪ Wise men say only fools rush in ♪
- How did you get into camming?
When I was 15 my dad kicked me
out because he wanted to live
with his girlfriend at the
time, who didn't like me,
and so I had to drop out
of school to get a job,
and I was working as a dishwasher.
I was working 10 to 14 hours
a day, and I knew I wanted
to do camming, but I waited
until a couple of months
after I turned 18; I figured
I would just try this
and see how it goes, and
it kind of saved my life,
because I was so miserable
doing what I was doing.
A lot of people think that
camming is just only like
having a webcam and masturbating,
but for me, for instance, it's about like
building a community
and bonding with people
and getting to know
people offline as well.
Growing up, for me, I was bullied,
and something that I found was helpful
was to be in chatrooms
online in places where
I could talk to other people online.
So this is why I enjoy
doing what I do so much,
because I'm still doing what I used to do,
like I'm just talking
to people in a chatroom.
- What's it like for your roommate?
How does that work?
- I had to make sure
she was okay, before she
moved in, with what I did,
and luckily she is, and
she's supportive of me.
For her, probably it sounds like I'm
just in a very enthusiastic Skype call.
- Soon after, Scarlet
informs her followers
that she's going live.
- So, right now,
people are just realizing that I'm live,
and they'll start coming in slowly.
- This person says, "Well hey Aria,
how has the day been going?"
So polite! My day is going swell.
So this is how a typical show goes?
- Yeah, so this is the warming up.
We already have almost
300 people watching.
- Scarlet currently makes
up to $700 per session,
with an audience averaging
around 2,000 to 3,000 viewers.
- Do you want to spank me,
or do you want to be spanked?
- These are questions I didn't think
I was going to be ready for today.
(slaps)
- How many is that, three?
- God damn it, Ryan. (slap)
- Alright, have a good day!
- Have a good day! (laughs)
These people are very friendly.
- Yeah, they are, this is what I mean.
A lot of rooms are not
where it's just all demands
and dirty things, a lot
of the time as well,
it's just like people
coming in for conversation.
- As the show progresses, more requests,
specifically for me, start to come in.
- Do you want to flash your feet?
- Oh, oh!
- Nordic guy says, "Can we
tip to get his clothes off?"
There's going to be no nudity here.
But luckily, as I knew I
couldn't get inappropriate
on camera, I already had
something up my sleeve.
You're gonna get something even better
than any show in a little bit.
- I'm really really excited for this.
- And she should be,
because since I didn't want
to let her viewers down,
I preemptively arranged
for a local theater
company to come join me
in the camming industry's first ever
live theatrical performance
of the classic 1980
musical spectacular, Les Miserables.
- I've always wanted to do Les Mis,
and not had the chance to do it before,
so I'm really excited to really nail
this version here that we're doing today.
(chanting)
- 2,000 viewers now.
- They want to see a show,
we're going to give them a show.
- They're going to get something.
- We can't mess this up.
- Les Miserables!
♪ As they turn your dreams to shame... ♪
- So how did you like the show?
- I loved it, I thought it was incredible.
♪ And there's his name! ♪
♪ Three days are all I need. ♪
♪ Then I'll return, I pledge my word. ♪
♪ Then I'll return. ♪
♪ You must think me mad! ♪
- (Scarlet) My viewers
loved it, they were writing
in the chat the whole time
how much they loved it.
It's not always sexual,
a lot of people come
for the entertainment value as well,
and that's what happened today.
People were joining to
see the entertainment
of what was going on with
the theater performance.
♪ Without me, his world
will go on turning ♪
♪ A world that's full of happiness
that I have never known! ♪
- (Scarlet) Can you imagine
just going into a room
and just jerking off for hours on end?
That's boring, you get bored
and you just leave eventually.
I have the entertainment
value, so you come,
you stay for my personality, and
then you also jerk off sometimes.
Camming is more than what meets the eye.
People don't understand that there's
a lot more that goes into it.
Some days I try to
think, and I'm just like,
if I could be doing anything
else, what would I be doing?
And I can't think of anything else,
because I always come back to camming.
I love camming and I love video-making.
Yeah, this is one of my favorite
times streaming as well,
this is the coolest thing I
think I've ever done on cam.
Everyone should check it
out, it's not a lonely thing,
cause a lot of people
assume that only lonely guys
go on there, but it's for everyone.
So I'm going to do this as long as I can,
as long as it's making
a sustainable income
and I'm happy doing it,
then I'm going to do it.
There's nothing else I'd rather be doing.
♪ Do you hear the people sing? ♪
♪ Singing the song of angry men, ♪
♪ It is the music of the people ♪
♪ Who will not be slaves again. ♪